der neue hat den job bestimmte nur über
lernen wann ist der hat den chef auch
mal mit seinem augen klimpern überzeugt
ja aber kaffee kochen können bestimmt
und schön anzusehen und irgendwie halt
habt ihr so was schon erlebt
wahrscheinlich eher nicht aber
andersherum wahrscheinlich schon
und das darf so nicht sein damit sich
das ändert müssen alle gemeinsam an
einem strang ziehen frauen und männer
wir haben männer gefragt was sie selbst
dazu sagen und feministen und
feministinnen gefragt was sie sich
wünschen
und falls ihr euch jetzt fragt was kann
ich denn tun dann schaut euch dieses
video an
[Musik]
der feminismus ist für mich in erster
linie dass alle leute zu betreiben
können ich will auch sagen dass ich
selber auch als mann der für mindestens
und schreiben kann einfach für rechte
von frauen einstellen kann zur für die
gleichen kämpfen stärker so sinnvoll
dass es diese bewegung gibt aber ich
höre auch so sagen dass diese wird es zu
übertreiben was ist ein völlig
feminismus wie würdest du es definieren
wir dies hat er darum wirklich
gleichberechtigung von männern und
frauen zu schaffen und mittlerweile ist
es eher wie drei männer noch ein
bisschen mehr rein und wie kann ich dann
doch noch ein bisschen nachtreten das
ist halt nicht mehr das muss mal ging
habe ich das gefühl der minister
momentan sind einfach die linksradikale
nur ein bisschen nervig feminismus soll
kein männer bashing sein ganz im
gegenteil ist es nach wie vor die
bewegung die sich dafür einsetzt dass
alle menschen gleichberechtigt sind und
frauen und männer die gleichen
möglichkeiten haben
ich war mit meiner kollegin lena in
mainz unterwegs und wir haben männer
dazu befragt und auch feministen und
feministinnen lara ist eine davon und
sie hat nicht immer gute erfahrungen
gemacht wie kann es denn sein dass du
kleine süße maus die ja so süß und sich
für themen wie der feminismus und
gleichberechtigung frauenrechte in
cetera einsetzt das geht du musst das
doch gar nicht sagt doch dass du
aussiehst und dann hat sich immer ganz
kurzem strahlen und weiß ja
und genau deswegen mache ich diese
arbeit vielen dank man könnte vielleicht
mein frauen in deutschland die dürfen
doch alles sie dürfen wählen sie dürfen
alles studieren sie dürfen in jedem
beruf arbeiten aber es gibt noch genug
ungleichheiten und ihr könnt es
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr hören aber
corona verstärkt diese ungleichheiten
auch noch ein beispiel wer kümmert sich
in der pandemie oftmals um die kinder
die mütter der anteil der familien in
denen die frau die kinderbetreuung
vollständig übernimmt hat sich im
vergangenen jahr von acht auf 16 prozent
verdoppelt wir haben uns umgeschaut und
wollen euch zeigen dass es auch in
deutschland immer noch strukturelle
ungleichheiten zwischen männern und
frauen gibt was bei unserer
straßenumfrage unter männern allen ein
begriff war der gender pay gap im jahr
2020 haben frauen 18 prozent weniger
verdient als männer
also durchschnittlich 18 eur 62 pro
stunde und männer 22 eur 78 wir haben
immer noch die vorstellung des frauen
teilzeit erwerbstätig sind also quasi
unterstützend erwerbstätig sind für das
haushaltseinkommen
daraus ergibt sich nicht nur eine ganz
fatale gender pay gap das ist der
stundenlohn sondern viel viel schlimmer
dadurch dass frauen weniger stunden
arbeiten wissen sich geringeres
lebenseinkommen wesentlich geringere
rente dann stehen sie da auch für
zwanzig dreißig jahre ohne von dem was
in ihrem leben wirklich alles gebucht
haben leben zu können
also einerseits arbeiten frauen weniger
um sich zum beispiel um die kinder zu
kümmern und andererseits bekommen frauen
auch manchmal für die gleiche arbeit
weniger geld
ich hab's mal erlebt dass ich
gleichzeitig mit einem mann eingestellt
wurde für die gleiche arbeit und monate
später haben wir dann über unser gehalt
gesprochen und dann kam raus dass ich
230 euro pro tag verdient habe und er
280 ironischerweise sind das rund 18
prozent unterschied also genau der
gender pay gap der mann sollten wir um
die sicherheit der familie die frau nur
mehr so sich um die familie halt halt um
die kinder und das finde ich auch gut so
weil genau wegen weil das halt so gut
funktioniert sind wir so weit gekommen
als menschen
also für die einen ist das eine eher
typisch mann und das andere eher typisch
frau was fällt euch dann noch ein
begriffe wie geld karriere kinder
familie sind die eher typisch weiblich
oder typisch männlich während gilt kann
ich nicht warum auch nicht wenn sie sich
also wenn ich entscheiden müsste würde
ich meine meinung wäre würde ich auch
männliche kinder weiblich und familie
auch endlich solche einstellungen kann
man auch messen im placid association
test geht es darum ob man bestimmte
begriffe jeweils stärker mit männern
oder mit frauen verbindet ich habe den
ganzen test gemacht
und obwohl ich mich hier so bewusst
damit beschäftige kam bei mir aus ich
habe eine starke assoziation von
männlich mit karriere und weiblich mit
familie also das ist fest in meinem
gehirn verankert und wahrscheinlich
nicht nur in meinem martin sperr
hinterfragt als feminist schon länger
was ist denn eigentlich typisch mann
dass man ist man oft eine art und weise
und vielleicht ist es auch das
aufwachsen als man gewohnt oder ein wird
beigebracht dass es okay ist wenn man
viel raum einnimmt oder auch eine
situation dominiert also stark seien
laut seien hart sein so vermeintlich
männliche attribute männern eben auch in
führungspositionen ziemlich viel raum
ein und nicht unbedingt weil sie besser
qualifiziert sind sondern weil das schon
seit jahren so gehandhabt wird
seit 2016 gibt es deshalb eine
sogenannte geschlechterquote die für
ungefähr 100 unternehmen in deutschland
gilt die besagt dass alle frei werdenden
posten in aufsichtsräten zu 30 prozent
mit frauen besetzt werden müssen über
das thema wird schon länger sehr
emotional diskutiert zuletzt anfang des
jahres über einen gesetzesentwurf der
die quote unter anderem auch auf
vorstände erweitern möchte damit sich
bei dem thema frauen in
führungspositionen endlich mehr tut
wir leben ja bisher in der welt wo wir
auch eine quote haben und diese wo man
das so zu sagen wir wenn wir uns
anschauen wer immer leer wird in die
aufsichtsräte befördern wir
führungslos ständiges fördert der geht
in die politik mehr und mehr bezahlt das
sind immer männer
das heißt wir haben die aktuellen system
in dem männer bevorteilt werden und die
quote versucht das eigentlich
auszugleichen
eine quotenfrau weckroth die frauen
jetzt in bezug auf wenn eine frau einen
posten gewählt wird den sie überhaupt
nicht verdient hat nur weil sie eine
frau ist wenn das die definition fällig
das ist so ziemlich die definition dafür
das ist natürlich einfach total
ärgerlich weil es zu einem schimpfwort
im prinzip verkommen ist aber eigentlich
ist es ja was gutes weil wir wissen
einfach mit anderen mitteln als der
quote wird gleichberechtigung im moment
nicht möglich sein dass in den 200
größten deutschen unternehmen entscheide
nur 11 5 prozent frauen in den
vorständen mit
das problem ist menschen neigen dazu
führungspositionen nach dem
ähnlichkeitsprinzip zu besetzen
also da waren bisher männer die stellen
eher männer 1 und qualifizierte frauen
werden nicht gesehen
seit 100 jahren wurde immer gesagt
frauen müssen sich darum kümmern dass
sie ihre rechte einklagen das heißt sie
müssen immer wieder darauf hinweisen wir
sind in einem ungleichen verhältnis mit
unseren männern in unserer gesellschaft
aber yuen will man hat eben seit 2010
spät genug ein paradigmenwechsel
eingeläutet in dem inzwischen mit dieser
wunderbaren aufgebauten initiative bsci
klar wird alle haben einen vorteil davon
wenn frauen auch in der gleichen weise
gefördert und lebens rechte ausüben
können wie männer
ergo müssen wir darauf hinweisen dass
ist nötig ist diesen paradigmen chef
hinzukriegen im denken nämlich beide
geschlechter profitieren davon dass sie
gleichberechtigte teilhabe haben dass
sie entscheiden dürfen gleiche rechte
gleiche pflichten gleiche verantwortung
für männer und frauen und das ist das
ziel
vielleicht könnte sich da etwas tun
unsere umfrage hat gezeigt dass das eine
männern auch schon bewusst ist und
könnte das auch ein termin ist auch ein
mann sein oder sind es eher nicht ganz
auf mann sein wenn ich glaube wenn nicht
muss ich definitiv auch männersache
weil sich ja niemand hinstellen und
sagen sollte das geht mich nichts an
dass ich bin halt ich bin jetzt niemand
der jetzt sondern auch die straßen
begeben salz macht für mich ist heute
ebenso der stille protest das ist eben
nicht so gut aber eigentlich ist das gar
kein stiller protest termin ist sein
bedeutet nicht nur auf die straßen zu
gehen und zu demonstrieren feminist sein
bedeutet auch dass man sich bewusst ist
dass es ungleichheiten gibt und dass man
selbst nicht so ist
ja ich bin nur weil man diskriminierung
zum beispiel nicht erlebt heißt es nicht
dass sie unsichtbar ist also im
gegenteil ich finde wenn man sich in so
einer privilegierten lage befindet in
der man selber nicht von diskriminierung
betroffen ist dann ist es doppelt
wichtig hinzuschauen und vor allem auch
das eigene verhalten zu hinterfragen
denn ich glaube dass man schon sagen
kann dass wenn männer nicht feminismus
und gleichstellung als eine aufgabe auch
für sie verstehen wir keine
gleichstellung oder keine
gleichberechtigung erreichen können
dh wir können kein gesellschaftlichen
wandel ohne die hälfte der bevölkerung
durchführen und von daher glaube ich
haben männer müssten männer teil von
sendung sei nicht auf männer müssen
teils mechanismus dahin damit er
wirklich diese diese neue welt schaffen
kann die wir wollen in der frauen-
männer- alle anderen gleich rechte
chancen möglichkeiten an
feminismus und männer sind keine
gegensätze sondern sie brauchen sich
gegenseitig das alles nutzte nicht nur
dem individuellen mann sondern es nutzt
und zwar gesellschaft und was unserer
gesellschaft nutzt schließt männern und
frauen in der gesellschaft gleichermaßen
um ein mögliches beispiel von jutta
allmendinger zu nennen die klassische
familie könnte dann so aussehen
bei der mutter und vater arbeit nur vier
tage die woche und teilen sich
gleichermaßen die kindererziehung
dann könnten beide sich beruflich
weiterentwickeln und hätten mehr zeit
für hobbys ist also gut für jeden
einzelnen für die beziehung und für die
kinder
also das heißt für
geschlechtergerechtigkeit brauchen wir
alle uns lieber männer das bedeutet eben
dieses privileg was du über jahrhunderte
ja draußen es für selbstverständlich
genommen hast jetzt mann über bord zu
werfen und so der welt zu kommen wo wir
gleichberechtigt sind und wo der facto
das leben für uns alle es war ist das
klingt jetzt vielleicht groß und
schwierig zu greifen deshalb haben wir
drei tipps beachten könnt erstens fragen
und zu hören
aber ich glaube der wichtigste tipp ist
als man frauen zu fragen und sagen
einmal zu fragen was bedeutet sexismus
wie fühlt sich das an und warum ist das
ein problem
aber auch zu fragen wie kann ich als
mann helfen zweitens danny mitbekommt
dass frauen benachteiligt werden könnte
darauf hinweisen und etwas sagen wenn
man bei mädchen bei der arbeit mit
kriegt jede frau aber übergangen wird
kann man daraus mehr hinweisen oder man
fragt die frau hey wie kann ich dich
beim nächsten meinem nächsten mission
unterstützen und drittens zeitgleich
solidarisch der frau gegenüber ja eine
situation dass in der u bahn ein mann
eine frau getränk wie verhalte ich mich
als andere mal ein anderer mann der das
beobachtet ich könnte mit karacho
reingehen und dem anderen mann als auf
die nase geben weiß nicht vielleicht
nicht so eine kluge idee aber vielleicht
eher unterstützen die frau fragen ob man
was tun kann irgendwie ob sie irgendwie
unterstützung braucht also gar nicht so
sehr in anführungszeichen den täter
nochmal bestärken und hat auf
konfrontation gehen sondern versuchen
irgendwie die situation herunter zudem
und und unterstützend helfend zur seite
zu stehen und jetzt kommt es auf euch an
auf männer frauen alle geschlechter seid
mutig und unterstützt euch gegenseitig
damit wir in einer geschlechtergerechten
gesellschaft leben und das gefühl
gemeinsam
[Musik]
egal zu welchem geschlecht gehört diese
fünf gedanken aus unserer fall finger
challenge könnt ihr euch machen um zu
überprüfen was läuft beim thema
geschlechtergerechtigkeit falsch nimm
ein finger runter wenn du schon mal
erlebt hast dass eine frau für den
gleichen job weniger geld bekommt nimm
einen finger runter wenn man jene
familie überwiegend deine mutter die
erziehung übernommen hat dem ein finger
runter wenn du schon mal gedacht hast
der rock ist ganz schön kurz und im ein
finger runter wenn du schon mal gehört
hast wie jemand gesagt hat guck mal der
so ein mädchen im ein finger runter wenn
du schon mal gehört hast wie gesagt
wurde
die ist sehr hübsch die braucht mal
wieder einen richtigen mann